[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play ascension this
is a game then I don't know where I got
it from again I've just downloaded a
bunch of games recently and I think it's
from gamejolt but I'm not exactly sure
so ergo I again do not know what it's
about but there's an eye in the middle
of that screen new game load game
website ok I don't have any previous
games so let's just go it actually is
very dark it dimmed my entire desktop
ascension is a horror game with an
emphasis on atmosphere and storytelling
for the best experience play the game in
a dark room with headphones check check
when playing the game you should not
play to win instead focus on immersing
yourself in the game use the WASD keys
to move that sounds familiar that's how
the beginning of amnesia went when you
first loaded up the game it reminded you
to not to play to win and just play to
experience a story scada
you can make it a D just two more days
oh hello well this is much different
than I had in mind
interesting yeah I had no idea that this
was into it okay cool well here's a
house of some sort I don't know what
that story is but based off the name I'm
guessing I'm ascending to become a god
what that okay hey buddy
it'll be the weekend then you can relax
for a bit maybe get some sleep just a
little before I have to go back to work
maybe viola will sleep in to that child
can okay never mind all right save game
I guess huh look how handsome I am now a
Sibelius
thought I was good-looking back then
gray hair wrinkles much more attractive
now also sarcasm this is actually really
cool I wasn't expecting this at all but
this is very well done
you can open doors by using the e key
very interesting well I haven't played
all that many 2d side-scrolling
platformers like this but it is a
welcome change
very well done hello you must be Cecilia
Oh viola deaconess you okay
I'm fine I want to go to school viola no
you are too ill I could have stayed home
I am NOT leaving you and what you're
working I don't have anything to do here
I'm imagining if the all these people
are from Latvia uh
I need to work to get daily potato there
was once time when we had many potatoes
but now we have none such is life see
you play with her now look she's coming
my friend is coming down hey Adi what's
up kill any mockingbirds lately
ha ha ha ha ha ah I do not kill birds
one day you'll get it oh is this your
daughter yep she's such a cutie hi
darling and yes this woman has a very
deep voice don't make fun of her and so
it's a daughter and so does the man well
the man has a higher-pitched voice
compared to viola - hello hi I have to
go to work now ok fine you can go
viola I'm fine
this is probably mocking me the
important things that are going on if
you hola please talk to your papa viola
I'm fine by myself don't do your work
she seems kind of upset that's just our
fears sure want her to go ok I'm done
making fun of this I'm actually trying
to get into the story a bit so everyone
ignore my ramblings I'm just a silly
youtuber who doesn't know how to do
anything maybe the three of us could go
get ice cream or something after work
okay sounds good not today
I think I'm tired okay okay alright so
apparently I got to go to work and I'm
some sort of construction worker judging
by my outfit
when does the spookiness start this
actually must be a much longer game that
I thought it was ergo there might be
some interesting things hello you look
like the guy from left 4 dead warning a
tea
good morning miles how's your day going
do not get me started I know what you
mean being down here really sucks of
life out of you I've already forgotten
what the Sun looks like I know I'm just
waiting for the weekend
how's your daughter he brought her in
today right kids the kids she's almost
as hiring his work I hear ya mine just
moved out for college I don't know what
to do with all the free time take a nap
see you later miles gets later alright
so I'm guessing I'm trying to go down to
work in the mines or something call the
elevator hello so what exactly am I
doing here why why is she such a handful
I have to work this cut skyros job just
to support her and she wants to play
children a civilian who is sabili our
cecilia Sibylla I'm not exactly sure why
am I going underground
all of these are excellent questions yes
I said kis Jin's I'm also not keeping
track of time okay so I've got this
really dark what's the dealio here
qingxue ah hello
emergency lights oh well that's not a
good thing
hello oh hello anybody can I get out of
here boingy-boing it huh oh hello there
we go okay we are on our way it's really
dark you need to find a way back quickly
I hope bill them
Amelia okay I hear someone typing the
distance I was actually sure break her
room oh this sounds like the right place
to go hey look a flashlight perfect
take flashlights thank God just what I
need
got it hello is someone out there
someone want to mess with me okay sandy
I fixed up the lights over in exports
they should work fine now well
apparently not your keys are on your
desk okay health pack pretty good this
game is definitely a lot more in depth
than I had in mind
duh buy this game I'm not sure I have no
idea really either way I need to find
the breakers
why would I need to hold my breath why
what's going on here I hear something
over there ah miles is that you her
healing people again what what was that
that was messed up man it was kind of
some cross between oh oh he's still here
hey I'm holding my breath you can't see
me well I can't see you but you can't
see me can i crouch why see okay I just
gotta move fast him okay here we go oh
oh jeez oh man that was awesome I was
actually a really well done mechanic for
horror games that was awesome
anyway take flattery got battery and
it's said something about a key being on
a desk so that's what I need to look for
someone's key is on someone's desk and
they're gonna go back out there turn off
you like to go in go in hold your breath
don't go it haha I hear him stepping
around I can hear footprints this looks
like it's gonna be an awesome game I
just and take out that good oh I can I
can open each one of these in no way no
I can't I can only open some nevermind I
thought wrong I need new batteries my
flashlight is about to die okay let's
just go oh crap
where is he where is he
how far over is he where is he okay hold
it hold it a little longer go go go I
think I went into a different office now
okay
I can barely see I definitely need some
new batteries there might be a way to UM
let me save at least ah something
strange is going on here no kidding I
have a very bad feeling about this how
about a worse feeling ah well at least
for those who are dead their struggle is
over is all good
alright why is a wiser light only
working in the bathroom
these season this is not good but soon
Drago will be over okay ah my battery my
old battery pack must have ran out so I
must open refill it automatically when
they run out okay sandy I fixed it wait
I already read that okay I got it I got
it I got it I'm back out here okay so I
need to find a way can I go in there
about you can you what did I come from
there or what what is oh I see okay
that's just a flat door okay never mind
I'm an idiot okay where does this lead
um reads sign left shipping warehouse
west stairs something about I remember
reading something about the shipping
warehouse okay I don't hear any monsters
any monsters want to jump out and scare
me we've known hello
read the note read it how about you read
it
okay don't read it never mind that
wasn't a good sound oh boy
flex it Oh running running running that
sounds like a something that sounds like
a some is this where I came from
oh lordy I am so screwed
I am so screwed so I got to find the
damn damn damn I gotta find the key in
one of these rooms here but I just do
not know where gotta go back in this
area with my good friend Jimmy cannibal
oh okay there's another area over here
okay so I can go this way and hopefully
not be murdered to death batteries yes
come more batteries are badass okay
there's there's gotta be keys on
someone's desk there's gotta be there's
gotta be oh hey it's not here dammit I'm
gonna have to go through all the offices
in there again oh man let me just pop in
and save before I end up killing myself
again is there something out there I'm
probably just paranoid you've already
been hit by it what are you talking
about what are you talking about besides
what could they possibly be working on
in here Oh looks like my internal glow
has increased quite a bit
that's good maybe the brightness in my
monitor is just decided no thank you I
do not want any please go away and die
in a fire no that's not an office is it
yes
how about guy he killed me dead oh I'm
like so damaged
I've already been in this area where
nothing is helping me I'm gonna die
aren't I
I've been in all of these blazes and my
flashlight is just okay I just refilled
my flashlight now that it's gonna do me
any good because there's a monster all
right right there damn it he's gonna
murder me I don't know where to go huh
Ron Ron Oh alrighty then what is that
that's a hand Oh got it oh there it is
ah found it I was in here before but it
just did not help me examine grass
Oh No please not now what what do you
mean not now grass
what's with the grass what do you mean
grass
oh you mean Oh like outbreaks super
disease grass that's what you're trying
to say buddy
wait I don't have a flashlight where'd
my flashlights go I lost a lot of things
what what is going on come on outside
now what is happening what's happening
what's happening what's happening whoa
whoa whoa what's happening
this is weird hey wait listen I wasn't I
hear wait a minute
this journal it's it's it's what the
babies do any time now I'm scared though
safe in the country wait hang on I'm not
even reading it I'm trying to skim
through it and you're going quickly
every day is harder doctor keeps telling
me to forgive a brave face but she knows
about my health record
I just hope Adi will be able to let me
go oh this must be about his wife okay
so I'm wandering around my house in the
dark that's healthy oh hi just uh
watching the fire there honey dearest
dad that's okay I'll ignore you like I
always have where we good
where am I wait where am I wait where am
I Who am I now
okay I'm somewhere I don't know where
though I'm in a different place than I
was
no thank you where am I oh that's not
good
that's not good this is all not very
good hello
that's even worse that's even worse is
not good too hardcore so hardcore ah
yeah you can't get me I'm the
gingerbread man [ __ ] I need a final
saving okay I haven't saved him like
forever I have died I'm assuming that I
was supposed to sneak by those areas but
if you know me you know that I don't
sneak about anything I am too hardcore
okay so anyway this is a good day a
place to stop seems like it Otto saved a
bit so thank you all so much for
watching check out this one hopefully I
can remember where I got it so I can
provide a link in the description below
so thanks again click the annotation for
more videos if knife gun and as always
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]